إذا تمكنا من عرض هذا الرسم البياني للولايات
المتحدة مقابل الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
فأنا أعتقد أن هذه نقطة مهمة
لأنه لم يكن من الضروري أن
تسير على هذا النحو في فلوريدا أو
بقية البلاد من حيث
العدد الإجمالي  حالات هضبة على ما يبدو
جون منذ أسبوعين مضت ، عشرين
ألفًا ربما نعود الآن إلى ما يصل إلى
خمسة وعشرين ألف حالة في
اليوم ، ولم يكن هناك حاجة للذهاب بهذه الطريقة ،
وهذا ما يجب أن يبدو عليه
، أعني أنه يجب على الناس أن يتذكروا
هذه الصورة حقًا على  الشاشة الآن
ما تظهره الولايات المتحدة نوعًا ما هو
أن الطابق السفلي لدينا هو أدنى مستوى
من المنحنى الذي يبدو أن هذا هو
الطابق السفلي لدينا وهذا ما نرتاح له
في هذا البلد ، حيث يصاب عشرين ألف شخص
يوميًا بالعدوى
سبعمائة ومئات من الناس يموتون
انظر إليك كل يوم ، هذا ما كان يجب أن
يكون عليه الأمر كما تعلم ، إنه رائع
سانجاي عندما تشير إلى
ذلك ونرى هذا الرسم البياني أمامنا مباشرة هذا
الاختلاف الصارخ بين  ما
يحدث هنا وما يحدث في
الاتحاد الأوروبي بعد أن سمعنا نائب
الرئيس بنس يقول أنك تعلم في
الأيام الأخيرة أن وسائل الإعلام قد
دقت ناقوس الخطر بشأن موجة ثانية من
الإصابات بفيروس كورونا ، فقد تم تضخيم هذا الذعر
إلى حدك الذي تعرفه
وكان كذلك  سمعنا من د.  Fauci الأسبوع الماضي
ما زلنا في هذه الموجة الأولى التي
تعرفها لأن بيتر نافارو كان يقول نعم ،
الإدارة تستعد لموجة ثانية ،
هل تعتقد أنهم يرون هذه
الأرقام ويخافون نعم ، أعني
أعتقد أنهم يرون  نفس
الأرقام التي نراها والتي نأمل أن يقوم
مسؤولو الصحة العامة
بتقديم المشورة لهم بشأنها على الرغم من أنه
ليس من الواضح أنك تعرف دون
عقد اجتماعات فرقة العمل المعنية بفيروس
كورونا بانتظام ولكن الأرقام
هي الأرقام ويمكنك مقارنتها
بأماكن أخرى  في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، كما تعلم ، أعتقد أن هناك
إحساسًا تسمعه أن النظرة إلى أن
هناك حتمية حول هذا الأمر ، فهذه
هي الطريقة التي كان سيجري بها الأمر ،
لا يوجد شيء آخر كان بإمكاننا القيام به ،
إنه مثل إعصار قادم  أو
شيء من هذا القبيل ، لكنك تعرف الآن إذا نظرت
إلى أوروبا إذا نظرت إلى آسيا وتايوان ،
فلديهم سبعة أشخاص ماتوا سبعة ، لذلك
تعلمون أن هذا على حدود الصين ومن
ثم تعرف مرة أخرى أنني
hink سيتم استخلاص هذه المقارنات إلى
الأبد ولكن لدينا فرصة
للتعلم من هذه الدروس
الآن لسؤالك إيريكا لا أعتقد أن
لدينا رفاهية التحدث عن
الموجة الثانية الآن
لأننا لم نخرج من  الموجة الأولى
وليس من الواضح أننا سنخرج
من الموجة الأولى بدلاً من أن
يكون لدينا نوعًا حقيقيًا من المد والجزر ،
فقد يكون فقط نوعًا ما تعرفه عن
القمم الصغيرة والكليّة التي تعرفها
للمستقبل المنظور